hello everyone and welcome to Scotland
like we mentioned in the previous video
and the one before that we will be
covering the double round-robin here in
the Lindor zabi whisky distillery played
between the four of them Magnus Carlsen
Vishwanathan Anand ding leerin and of
course Sarah Kerrigan who is
unfortunately for him knocked out of the
feed a grand prix by alexander greased
rock so before we check out the game we
do have a nice photo of the four of them
it's not over the highest quality it is
from the official indoors ABI website
there we have it
Anand Kirk in Causton and of course the
England doing his usual the I don't know
where where the camera is but I we're
all pretty much used to that by now
it's important you know to play good
chess nothing else really matters and
you have the gentleman to the right of
them I mean they are in Scotland so III
do believe everything makes sense and as
it's Crossan versus Anand I prepared
some scores between the two of them for
you to check out here here they are
we're gonna disregard the classical
games it is 12 to 8 but it's fairly
fairly close you know with 46 draws what
we're interested in is only rapid
exhibition games it's 14 to 11 in
Carlson's favor with 25 draws so Crossan
leading by 3 points in Rapids and it's
it's always a good opportunity for Anand
to lower the lead and like I said it's a
these will be rapid games it's 25
minutes per player plus 10 seconds
increment so it can you know a last I
believe to about an hour and maybe 20
minutes or more depending on how many
moves they play and as a special
occasion for this video as you know this
is being played in the old windows abbey
whiskey distillery I will have a nice
sip of whiskey before checking out this
game you know just to get in the mood
for this video so you know Cheers
[Music]
I never really drink whiskey and more of
a rakia guy but then again I've never
actually tried a good one so I mean
maybe that's the reason I don't know but
that being said let's check out the game
Carlson has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 with Knight to f6 with c4
e6 Crossing goes Knight to c3 so we're
not going into the Queen's Gambit the
client but rather in Bishop to b4 there
goes in defense with III by Carlson
castles by Anand and now Bishop to d3
nicely developing the bishop on this
long diagonal we have d5 and now comes
seek actress on d5 with eek after sandy
v and now Knight to e2 defending the
knight here also preparing the castle
and rook to e8 by Anand with Bishop to
b2 and here comes b6 preparing to
fianchetto the light square bishop we
have castles by crossing and now comes
Bishop to d6 there are a few moves known
in this position it's not a new position
Bishop the b7 is a known move here c6 is
a known move here a5 is a known move
here Bishop to f8 is a known move here
but the move Anand plays Bishop to d6
has never been played before and it is
now as a mu 9 that we had a completely
new game on our hands so let's see how
Carlsen goes about it first
look the c1 and as soon as I saw this
rook to see one move I thought wow this
was a very nice move because I don't
know you always I mean your spidey sense
always has to be tingling what about
Bishop captures on h2 I mean everything
this seems to be setup Bishop here night
here Queen here
what's with the classical Bishop
sacrifice does it work here well
probably not since Carlson did allow it
but let's just check out what happens as
that always interests me if Bishop
captures on h2 you capture with the King
Knight g4 check and now you don't go
back of course if you go back when H 4
and now you are getting checkmated what
you have to do after Knight g4 check is
go King to g3 and Carson doesn't mind
this adventurous idea but it's a very
nice line and we will show it why
Carlsen allowed it first
h5 putting pressure here and defending
the knight h4 also being a possibility
now rook the h1 now
after h4 check rook captures on h4 now
comes Knight captures on f2 trying to
get calls in to capture so on and can
capture the look on h4 but then comes
Bishop to h7 check King to h8 and now
Bishop the back to be one check checking
to see whether the King was going to go
to f8 or h8 and now only if the King
moves for example if you go here then
Queen to c2 will be deadly
with the dis plan so you would have to
capture the rook here Queen captures an
h4 King captures and now Knight captures
on d1 and here you could capture the
night but even better is Knight captures
on d5 going after c7 to fork the rooks
and after black defends this Knight day
six only now do you recapture the night
and after all is said and done it's 5
points each but Magnus would have a
bishop in the night for a rook so it
would be well much better for white but
that's the point and as soon as I salute
to c1 as I thought what about Bishop
captures well it doesn't work
otherwise a nun would would have played
it
we have c5 a flank attack on the center
here and now nice to b5 cousin doesn't
want this bishop to have this option
forever and it still doesn't work so on
and just retreats Bishop to f8 save the
bishop for later with f3 taking away the
e4 n g4 Square from block from blacks
night and now Knight to c6
Anand continuous development with roof
to h1 by Carson and now Bishop the b7
putting the bishop on this very nice
diagonal a3 and now g6
so now cousins Bishop will not be all
that impressive and maybe the bishop can
also be seeing kettle to g7 to assume
this diagonal we have Bishop the b1
cross and tucks the bishop in for later
but also prepares to lifted over to a2
so now the bishop is coming to this
diagonal so very nice game how both
cousin and Anand are trying to get their
bishops to - you know more squares with
the most activity
rook the c8 by Anand and now comes
Bishop to a2 as planned with a6
first before deciding what to do you
don't want this nice to constantly be
here so a 6 we have knight back to c3
and now rush up to G
seven and here Colson goes for a capture
with decad force on c5 b captures on c5
and now Bishop the e1 now both the Queen
the rook and the pawn are controlling
the d4 square also the bishop if needed
can come to f2 or maybe even g3 to grab
hold of this diagonal with d4 by Anand
and now Carlson is not interested in
making a trade he goes Knight to a4 and
repairs the capture on c5 so what can
undo here well it's very important
crucial if I might say to go either
Queen to e7 or Knight to e5 but it will
only later be revealed why these are the
two best options for black here I don't
play Knight to d7 he didn't like this
pawn captures an e3 idea but for a good
reason
here he played a night here he first
wants to defend his c5 pawn and only
then decide what to do with the dis pawn
if Carlson captures then on and favours
the trade and of course an advances then
and we'll have a nice past D pawn on the
board but here he missed one idea from
Carlson so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the idea on the
mist here in this position I'll give you
a couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent
you know grabber of the f7 pawn and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show of course you see this Bishop
characters Queen b3 trick picks up the
bishop on b7 so that's the idea Bishop
captures on f7 would check King captures
Queen b3 check King has to move we have
King to f8 you can no longer escape this
way so King to a fate and now comes
Queen captures on b7
and here rook captures on e3 so the
material on the board is equal but there
is one difference first cross and gets
rid of the knight and g3
puts it to g3 so it will not be under
attack here on e2 and now what do you do
here we have night night CT 5 and here
Crossan has to decide does you want to
capture the ace exponent which is
possible if he captures the pawn then
you get rook to e8 now the Queen has to
move as the knight will also be under
attack we have Queen to d6 width check
King to g8 and now Knight
actress on c5 Knight captures on c5 and
now Queen captures on c5 and here you
can go Knight to d3
attacking the rook and the Queen but
Queen to c4 check and after King to h8
you will have this position where of
course the white is better you're up to
pawns but black has a lot of activity a
very strong bishop and already a passed
pawn on d4 so it's a bit of a trade-off
but why white should be preferred here
so after Knight see to e5 Carlsen
doesn't bother himself with da six point
he goes Bishop to d2 first kicks the
rook back we have looked a d3 now with
an attack on the bishop here and now
comes Knight to e4 just defending that
Bishop on d2 and here looked to be it on
and kicks away a call since Queen and
here we have Queen to d5 and it's a very
difficult position now because you do
have to do something with this rook here
and also there is the the pretty big
threat of Bishop to g5 for example if
you try to get the rook back into the
game with something like rook to b3 then
Bishop to g5 is deadly you attack the
Queen after the Queen moves Queen c7 now
you just capture the c5 pawn Knight
captures here after Knight captures you
will capture again as well now again
you're threatening in this check to win
the Queen
so here black would have to move the
Queen Queen f7 96 check for example King
g8 and now troop to c7 would win the
game the Queen is under attack after the
Queen moves rook captures and g7 is
deadly this is only one of the options
after Carlson's Queen to d5 and so
that's hard to decide what to do how do
you prevent the Bishop to g5 you could
try h6 this does prevent Bishop to g5
but then f4 is very strong you force the
knight back after Knight of seven f5 you
threaten to open up the F file and your
rook already nicely occupies the same
file as the black king so after g5 you
would go Bishop to a5 attacking the
Queen a very nice idea if you capture
well then a white can capture here but
if you move the Queen for example Queen
to it then f6 comes and it's just too
hard to play this for black Bishop to h8
you will go Knight to d6 now attack the
Queen and the night here
for example captures captures with check
King to f7 and now Knight captures and
c5 again it all comes down to this night
capture so we have rook captures
Hennigan rook to c7 will be a really a
terrible threat if you defend it than
just Queen d5 check King g6 and now
Queen a5 check will be will be perfectly
sufficient to create a king of seven
queen h7 check you can pick up the Rope
here so not much black can do here
so after Queen to d5 not not a lot of
good ways to prevent Bishop to g5 so
Anand tries rook captures and e2 if you
can't prevent it to just eliminate the
bishop with Knight captures on D - but
now Knights the d3 attacking the rook
here we have rook to c2 by crossing and
now Queen to e7 and here at nights the
e4 closes the file for the Queen and
also the c5 pawn is now under under
heavy fire we have Knight to a4 by Anand
attacking call since Queen and now Queen
to c4 and it was indeed in fact in this
position I'll move 31 that Vishwanathan
Anand resigned the game and Magnus
Carlsen takes his first win here in
Scotland in the Eleanor's Abby whiskey
distillery as he drew his game against
England in round one he drew the second
game against Sevilla kirkin which was
also very nice but then in third again
he was able to defeat which want an
island so after the end of the first day
across and Engler north hard for a tie
for first place both of them with one
victory and and sorry and Vishwanathan
Anand and Sarah Baker keen are sharing a
third and fourth so that's the game here
he resigned because he's down the
exchange but there's a really no good
way to there's no good way to take
anything from it you don't really have
any compensation and well d3 seems like
a reasonable idea yes but then the
problem is Knight captures on c5 and
here you're threatening Knight captures
you're threatening Queen captures on f4
so even if the rook is captured you can
just capture here with check if Queen
captures then you capture here with
check and after King moves
g7 or you block with the bishop doesn't
really matter whenever you try Queen
will capture rockin b8 and it will just
be well - too much material for white
and there's no way - Queen there's
nothing nothing to do here and on the
other hand after this Queen to c4 move
you could also try something like rook
to ca to just try and protect the pawn
but white will just grab it Knight
captures Knight captures Knight captures
now you already lost lost the pawn
you're down the exchange this is now a
weak pawn you will just solidify the
position win that point as well continue
on pushing your own Queen side pawns
create a passed pawn a lot a lot of ways
to victory here and if for example after
Queen to c4 you could try Knight e5
attacking the Queen then just Queen
captures on c5 and black has really has
no tricks to try here swept after this
Queen to c4 on and resign the game and
then a very nice victory for for Magnus
Carlsen so that's what the first game
we're covering here of tomorrow morning
I will check out the the game between
Bingley Ryan and Sarah Kerrigan I might
also cover that one but we'll still see
about that and yeah I mean tomorrow is
the end if if all the games after all
the games have ended if there is a tie
then they are going into tie breaks and
of course it will be a blitz three plus
two so we will have a very nice game now
cross an ending liran are tied and if
they will be tied tomorrow it will be
very interesting to see because last
time Carson played the match against
ding leerin the one where they had rapid
+ blitz games across and just
obliterated England so it will be very
interesting to see if ding has something
prepared against Carlsen and will he be
able to put up more of a resistance this
time but you know there are still games
tomorrow so it could be anyone's
anyone's tournament but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it we can
once again check out this very nice
photo for the last time I mean if you
enjoyed it I certainly have just a very
nice photo sure there we have it
I would like to thank Josiah foster
akali dal hi Jerry and Lawrence Golding
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon
hopefully with more interesting content
covering everything that we're covering
so far the finals of the feeder Grand
Prix cover Blanca saga this tournament
and of course checking up on your
suggestions as always I think I will
soon have an excellent rest of your
Saturday